♪
♪.
MARIA: WELCOME BACK BREAKING
NEWS BRAND-NEW APPREHENSION
NUMBERS FOR THE MONTH OF JUNE
FROM OUR SOURCE BRANDON JUDD THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL BORDER
PATROL COUNCIL, HERE ARE THE
UNOFFICIAL NUMBERS THAT WILL
PROBABLY GO HIGHER BECAUSE THIS
IS UP UNTIL TODAY, JUNE BORDER
ENCOUNTERS NATIONWIDE 174,000 IN
THE MONTH OF JUNE, 39000 PLUS
CUTAWAYS IN OTHER WORDS THOSE
PEOPLE WERE SEEN ON
SURVEILLANCE, THEY GOT AWAY WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEIR
INTENTIONS ARE THERE NOW IN
AMERICA ACCORDING TO BRANDON,
THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING
EVERYWHERE LITTLE ROCK,
CHARLOTTE, DES MOINES IN NEW
YORK CITY AND MIAMI, MAJOR
HOTSPOTS FORGOT A WAYS, TUCSON,
ARIZONA ALSO A REAL HOTSPOT
FORGOT A WAYS, CONGRESSMAN LEE
ZELDIN THE HOUSE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE AND RUNNING AS
GOVERNOR AS NEW YORK, GOOD
MORNING TO YOU YOUR REACTION TO
THE NEW NUMBERS AS WE EXPECT
SOME OF THEM TO GO TO NEW YORK,
WHICH CAN HE TELL THEM.
>> IT’S A STAGGERING CRISIS AT
HER BORDER RIGHT NOW, REALITY IS
SETTING IN, WE HAVE AS MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS AND OATH THAT
PROVIDE FOR THE COMMON DEFENSE
FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND ICING
CUSTOM BORDER PATROL, WE SHOULD
BE STRENGTH IN HER BORDER
ENFORCING A RULE OF LAW AND WE
TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO COME
ACROSS HER BORDER AND GIVES YOU
LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS WE ALSO
HAVE TO TAKE ACCOUNT FOR THE
THINGS THAT COME ACROSS THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING AND ARMS
TRAFFICKING, THE STORY BEHIND
THESE NUMBERS OFTEN TIMES LABOR
TRAFFICKING AND TRAFFICKING AS
WELL, IT’S IMPORTANT FOR THOSE
IN GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE ALL THE
RESOURCES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
DO THEIR JOB SAFELY, EFFECTIVELY
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT CROSSES THE
BORDER BUT IT QUICKLY SPREADS TO
CITIES AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
MARIA: OF COURSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
CLEANED ALL OF THIS UP BUT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OVERTURNED,
WORKING TO SPEAK WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND IF 30 SECONDS
TIME, REAL QUICK WHAT IS YOUR
PLAN TO TURN AROUND WHAT IS
TAKING PLACE IN NEW YORK YOU
HAVE MURDER RATES SKYROCKETING
IN U.S. CITIES AND 35% UP IN
ATLANTA, 24% UP IN L.A.,
MINNEAPOLIS 85% CRIME ALSO
SKYROCKETING IN NEW YORK, WHAT
IS THE PLAN.
>> SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT
MORE AND NOT LESS, REVERSE
CASHLESS BAIL, KEEP QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY AND ACTIVE BILL OF
RIGHTS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
RECOGNIZES SELF-DEFENSE THAT
GIVES THEM THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE UNFAIRLY TARGETED, I WAS
RAISED IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOUSEHOLD I’M HEARING IT FROM
ALL ACROSS THE STATE FROM PEOPLE
ALL WALKS OF LIFE THEY WANT TO
STRENGTHEN PUBLIC SAFETY IN OUR
STATE.
MARIA: LEE ZELDIN IS GREAT TO